because to me
the glory
in what i do is the fact that it starts
with a blank piece of paper you look at
something like inglorious bastards and
that did not if my mother never met my
father that would not exist in any way
shape or form quentin it's not your job
to create
your vision it's your job
[Music]
to have a vision a good majority of
movies that come out all right you
pretty much know everything you're going
to see in the movie by the first 10 or
20 minutes now that's not a story
a story is something that constantly
unfolds the only responsibility i have
is to be true to my characters and the
dialogue just comes out of the character
i don't leave the characters i let the
characters lead me why the need for so
much gruesome graphic violence why not
let us know because it's so much fun
chan get it it's hard work
to go to that blank piece of paper and
start from square ones start from
scratch every single solitary time i
want to make movies
that
people will watch them and that will
make them want to make movies you should
have this little voice inside of you
saying tell the truth
tell the truth tell the truth i actually
really try to
have morality not even be an issue at
all all right when it comes to my
character so i like the idea that you
open up the briefcase in pulp fiction
and i don't tell you what's in there but
it's up to you to figure out what's in
there and now that's your movie you make
a goddamn kick-ass movie
and you can take it all over in planet
earth
[Music]
you can see all kinds of movies but when
a movie really really does it to me it's
because it's um
it's made me feel many different
emotions
during the course of it and especially
if i can pull off contradictory emotions
that can actually
work out and i do believe that uh i'm
the kind of director that i'm um
i want to
i want to play you
as an audience i i want to be the
conductor
and
you're my orchestra
and the sounds that i make you to make
and the feelings i get you to feel and
then i stop you from feeling those
feelings and i give you something else
to feel and then i stop you from feeling
that and make you feel something else
yet again but when i read hard times
then i could see what a script could be
it was exciting it was fun and it wasn't
just the dialogue and you know the
cheney and that movie doesn't say much
all right um
but
but uh james coburn does a lot of
talking all right but um
but the point being though
was
it wasn't just description
it was
pros now not pros like i'm used to in a
novel but it was a prose that was
appropriate for a screenplay he he
wasn't just giving um a blueprint for
how a bunch of technicians can make this
movie later like a recipe for a cake
that somebody else is going to bake
he was the pros was written for me the
reader
i was supposed to get caught up into
this
i was supposed to to be excited about
this story i was supposed to get caught
up in the story and even more
importantly i was supposed to make the
movie in my mind when the script was
over and i put it down i saw it i saw
the movie
my movie there's like okay there's a
real famous scene and if you've read any
reviews on the movie you probably heard
about it right the the this torture
scene
the scene is about a guy mr blonde he's
a psychopath who tortures a hostage cop
in a court in the course of the movie
it's not like i was just sitting around
one day thinking man i'm gonna come up
with this really [ __ ] and torches thing
that everyone's gonna be freaking out
about it's not about that
the bottom line there is
that is what mr blonde would do when
left alone with that guy
saying you don't like violence in movies
is the same thing as saying you don't
like slapstick comedy in movies or you
don't like dance sequences and movies
you may not like it and that's fine you
don't have to like it all right but that
doesn't mean you shouldn't make it
the only responsibility i have is not
what a couple of knuckleheads might do
when they see the movie which
can be proven anyway all right the only
responsibility i have is to be true to
my characters and if violence or sex or
whatever all right is part of your
palette as an artist you got to be
allowed to paint
quentin it's not your job
to create
your vision
it's your job
to have a vision
and then it's your job
to hire
talented
individuals
hire talented artists who understand
your vision
and you articulate it to them
and then they
take your vision
and they create it
why do you write it right you know you
should have this little voice inside of
you saying tell the truth yeah tell the
truth tell the truth all right reveal a
few secrets the truth is your life
experience exactly that's the truth is i
know it to me all the movies are very
personal all right when i look at them
and i don't mean like i'm some
crook all right but the thing about it
though is like you know this group of
friends will look at it and be like oh
quinn i can't believe you talked about
that yeah you know you know this old
girlfriend because they identify with
their experience
you know it's like it's you know it's it
you should be semi embarrassed about
certain people seeing your movie i think
when you're finished if you're working
on a personal level or else the work is
not authentic
well i mean i don't want to make
that blanket a statement but but i guess
for me i guess yeah yeah
you don't have to know how to make a
movie
if you truly love cinema
with all your heart
and with enough
passion
you can't help but make a good movie
you don't have to go to school
you don't have to know a lens you know a
40 and a 50 and a [ __ ] all that [ __ ]
crossing the line none of that shit's
important if you just truly love cinema
with enough passion
and you really love it
then you can't help but make a good
movie
why the need for so much gruesome
graphic violence why not let us know
because it's so much fun jan get it oh
really okay i'd like to see you walk
down the street and get attacked by some
kids who's just seen but you saw me see
jan you're all messed up because you're
talking about real life
if you want to talk about the movies
we'll talk about the movies okay
people talk about real life kids at 12
can tell the difference you tell their
parents that quentin i was great i saw
movies when i was a kid all right i saw
the all the movies that i'm basing my
movie how wonderful are these movies i
thought i was kidding yes kids go to a
movie theater they can tell the
difference maybe you couldn't when you
were a kid but i could you get great
performances from these actors yeah why
is that you think
uh well because it really stands out in
a lot of your movies obviously well you
know it kind of i think it's a it's a
three prong thing you know um
i write good characters all right
interesting characters
uh i then i cast them well i cast them
well and uh but part of casting well is
usually unless i'm writing it for
somebody in particular sometimes that
works out and sometimes that doesn't um
uh
it's about the character first it's not
the actor first i my i don't have an
obligation to give a groovy actor a role
i have an obligation to find the best
person to play my character they're my
characters they came from deep in my dna
and i want them to have the perfect
person to play them i'm not writing
theater where you know everybody for the
next 20 years gets a crack at it
this is it we not only see she is a
bride but she's eight months pregnant
interior wedding chapel day overhead
shot
we hear
step
step
step
to a man we haven't seen yet enters the
shot
right next to the fallen bride
he lowers down next to her on his
haunches holding a white handkerchief
with the name bill stone in the corner
and begins tenderly wiping away the
blood from the young bride's face
while still in her close-up the bride
speaks for the first time in the picture
she looks up at the man standing over
her and says bill it's your baby
a beat after she says the word baby
we hear a bang
and the bride receives a bullet on the
side of her head cut to black screen
the fourth film by quentin taranti
just when it comes to uh the actual
writing of the piece where it really
really becomes what it is going to
become
is
it's about character and the dialogue
just comes out of the character and
i don't leave the characters i let the
characters lead me
both as far as who they are
and the conversations and even the
scenario itself i mean like for instance
if i've got a character here with this
glass and i have every intention of
getting them to where that glass is yeah
well that's a good idea my part i think
but once i get them going there they
might not they might reject the glass
right and they go somewhere else and
they are the ones that know best that
used to be the thing about america was
the fact that hollywood forget america
hollywood hollywood used to that's what
we did better than anybody else in the
world we told a really good story you
know europe was where you had
character-based films or mood-based
films but america we told the story
we're the worst at it now as far as i'm
concerned
telling a story i'm telling a story we
don't tell a story we tell a situation
most of the movies that you see nowadays
and i'm not a hollywood basher because
enough good movies come out of the
hollywood system every year to justify
its existence you know but they without
any apologies however
a good majority of movies that come out
all right you pretty much know
everything you're going to see in the
movie by the first 10 or 20 minutes now
that's not a story
a story is something that constantly
unfolds i'm not talking about like this
quick left turn or a quick right turn or
a big surprise i'm talking about it
unfolds i remember after i came out with
pulp fiction so i had two movies by that
time
uh some critic said something to the
effect of tarantino will never be a
master of suspense because he's too far
in love with minutia and i actually
thought that was a fair enough criticism
back then
so
in now i want to actually do a movie
where i actually indulge in suspense and
i go for it and my method of it and use
that scene in the opening scene of the
movie as an example
it's like um
it's like there's there's the scene
above ground and the scene below ground
and the scene above ground is what's
going on and the dialogue and them
sitting around this table and talking
underneath it
it's like the suspense is a rubber band
and i'm just stretching it and
stretching it and stretching and see how
far it can stretch now normally in a
situation when you do a movie
you try to make your scenes as compact
as possible so there's not air and you
don't wear out you're welcome with the
audience but under this method
as long as that rubber band can stretch
the longer the scene can hold
the more suspenseful it is that scene is
more suspenseful at 22 minutes and would
be at 8. so you want to just stretch it
until the rubber band breaks it's not
the whole movie isn't about redemption
but redemption does keep working itself
in to the movie and
most of the characters in the movie are
given choices to make and they
make the choices that they make and they
pay and they pay the price or the
consequences or they live to tell the
tale
uh because of those choices and we
actually see it happen all three
different times in the movie and uh but
actually but it's it's funny though if
you if you just take that for what it is
if you just look at the case of john
travolta and sam jackson it would
suggest
well okay sam jackson made the good
choice made the right choice unless he
prospers and
john travolta pays no attention to it
and thus we know he dies but you have to
but you have to think about bruce willis
choice
that happens in this movie because he
actually makes two choices one he makes
a choice to do a very unhonorable thing
you know he actually makes the deal with
marcellus wallace to throw the fight he
doesn't have to
marcellus doesn't say throw the fighter
you're dead
he makes it for money and he takes the
money and he screws marcellus with it
um but he actually ends up living to
tell the tale because he actually does
make a moral choice later when he goes
back to save marcellus uh running
glorious bastards i started uh writing
during the daytime where i get up and
you know it's like you know so around 10
30 or 11 o'clock or 11 30 i would sit
down and write
and uh like a normal work day
and i would sit down and i would uh
write until
4 5 six or seven somewhere around there
i would stop
and then i have a pool and i keep it
heated so it's nice
and i'd go into my so if i finished
okay so either i'm not finished with the
sequence or i've just finished the
sequence and i've got to figure out what
to do next so if i haven't finished the
sequence then i'd hop in my pool and
just kind of float around in the warm
water and think about everything i've
just written and and you know
how i can make it better or what else
can happen as far as before the scene's
over and then a lot of [ __ ] would come
to me literally a lot of a lot of things
would come to me and then i'd get out
and i would make little notes on that
but not do it and that would be my work
for tomorrow or if i just finish the
scene
all right i would think okay i'd go back
over it in my head in the pool and think
about it now okay now uh now what's the
next scene and now what's next and then
i figure out a few things and make notes
and that's my work for the next day and
that's ended up becoming this really you
know really enjoyable
really kind of lovely way to write and i
just want the actors to know now the
audience doesn't need to know like for
instance
uh brad pitt's character aldo lorraine
has a rope burn
exactly around his neck but i never want
to explain what i desperately wanted to
know well i want you to just figure it
out all right i mean that's up to you to
to supply where that rope burn came from
i mean i would love to have had a little
bit of a conversation that he would have
referred to that yes i i i wanted you to
know i would have told you i like the
idea but your idea of cinema then is it
keep a lot of stuff in you want mystery
in the film itself you know it's like
you want us not to know everything well
i like the idea i like the idea that if
okay if you contemplate why there is a
rope burn there and somebody else
contemplates why there's a roper and
there and somebody else contemplates it
and three different people come up with
three different uh reasons why he got a
roper and those are three different
movies you all saw and i like that idea
i like the idea that you open up the
briefcase in pulp fiction and i don't
tell you what's in there but it's up to
you to figure out what's in there and
now that's your movie
and you'll make that decision somewhere
down the line now if i tell you at this
table what it is then you'll throw that
away and i don't want you to throw away
that's your movie
when i'm writing the script
even though i'm thinking about cinematic
things and this and that and the other
when i'm putting pen to paper it's f the
movie it is about the page it is really
seriously about the page i'm writing
literature at this point my stuff gets
published and it is about it working on
the page i put scenes
in the script that i kind of know i'll
never film but because i don't think the
script will i don't think the movie will
need it but the written script needs it
it clarifies it for the reading it makes
it better for the reading yeah and part
of my job is to kind of
realize what i don't need as i'm making
the movie now once
i'm making the movie then i'm not only
thinking about the script that much and
now i'm making the movie but when it
comes time to the writing of it it
really is about the pen and the paper
and nothing else and not only that not
only i add one other thing to that yeah
is uh and i feel i need to feel this way
this way i know that i've done a good
job
is
if i've done the script and i do what i
want to do
then
i have to question the idea of you know
what
if i don't make this movie if i just
publish this i'm done
i'm done and i've got it i've won all
right it's mine to f up right if i go on
but right now i've d i'm done now i
don't do that i go and make the movie
but i always consider it
and if i don't feel that way about the
script and i know i haven't done that
good of a job yeah if you if you get the
passion if you get the passion to do it
and you do it and it doesn't like work
out i i worked for
got three years on a 16 millimeter film
that ended up becoming nothing but
guitar picks and uh
and i was very disappointed when i
realized it wasn't any good but it was
my film school all right and i actually
got away really cheap when it was all
over i knew how to make a movie i didn't
want to show anybody that but i had the
experience i had a lot cheaper than i
would have gone if i'd gone to film
school this was my film school all right
and this was the best film school a
person could possibly have i mean i
actually instead of like going to school
and paying a ton of money to be allowed
to use some of their crappy equipment
all right i actually went out and
actually tried to make make a feature
film i actually really
try to
um
have morality not even be an issue at
all all right when it comes to my
character it's so interesting i mean you
know i don't want that to have any play
whatsoever i that would be me commenting
on them right that is me sticking my big
nose into their lives and then their
philosophies i let them be who they are
and you know my biggest feeling is
you know i i just i just want the same
rights that a novelist has i mean like
we lived through the 80s we're like
[ __ ] every hollywood movie everyone
had to be likable and everybody had to
be understandable and uh and the test
scores were like oh well we didn't like
him so we got to change every goddamn
thing you know and uh i didn't make
movies at that time but i was watching
them and i said i'm not going to make
that crap and um
and i just want the same freedom that a
novelist has i mean you can make a novel
you can write a novel about a bastard
but it can be totally interesting i
think it's still possible for a upcoming
filmmaker to go the route you guys went
and still be successful
make reservoir dogs
that's a tough thing no i'm not even
being as i'm not even being a smart ass
that was a [ __ ] kick-ass movie all
right you make a goddamn kick-ass movie
and you can take it all over and planet
earth not america nothing los angeles
not new york the planet
earth and everyone will know it
but there is a lot more competition than
there was when i was you know like
kicking around with el mariachi so you
got you know there's just a lot more to
do but at the same time though yeah
there's a lot more to competition but
also those crappy movies aren't
competition if [ __ ] thing is like a
dynamite
yeah all that [ __ ] is you know yeah
there's a lot of a lot of people out
there doing stuff but if you know it's
like waves on the beach all right you
make some you make a piece of nitro that
you throw in an audience's lap though
people notice when you think that you
have this one more film to make
is there more weight on that or you just
do your [ __ ] thing
the weight was really on once upon a
time in hollywood really that's kind of
like my big
epic that's like my big wrap up wrap up
the career
kind of epic and i think i
did it so i don't know what the next
story is going to be
uh i'm imagining it'll be more epilogy
like this is the big one
and then whatever i end up doing for
that last one like i said a bit more of
an epilogue just as you're
wrapping up the career but you don't
have a specificity i have no idea i have
no idea well the only thing i can no
no i want to i i i i hope to do two more
books
and well let me one more book and then
do a play and then we'll see where we
are let's see if the another story has
come i mean the only one i can imagine
where i would
where it would be another epic where i
need to
outdo
everything as if i did a kill bill 3.
have you thought of that i thought of it
yeah
you